hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh [ __ ] march 22nd
2021. you know i think it was about a
year ago
that i was telling everybody to relax it
was going to be 14 to 18 days everybody
just [ __ ] stay inside
all memories
like the freckles on my dick
um
um oh billy got vaccinated
like once a pfizer did you jump the line
you pasty [ __ ] [ __ ]
um yes and no yes and no
um i guess i i wasn't
i think they now open it up to um
to entertainers although they did they
weren't entertaining that in northridge
like i said when i went up there we were
like yeah we're entertainers like yeah
we don't give a [ __ ]
but they said on the website the website
and us are two different things even
though they're connected to us all right
thank you
always wanted to see this parking garage
goodbye
um
no it was the end of the day at a
uh at a drugstore and my buddy had just
got vaccinated down there and he said
they got two left and they throw him out
at the end of the day
can you get down here i was like i can't
get down there until [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] way i can get all the
way down there from my house at this
hour
oh yeah that's crazy talk and then he
talked to the lady
god bless her she said i'll hang around
i don't want to throw him out it's a
waste
so i said [ __ ] it and i called up
another comic buddy of mine who will
remain nameless
and uh we
you know i said hey you know we got to
get down there in like an hour he goes
oh
that's a rough one um no it wasn't
rodney dangerfield he's passed away
we so we drove down there and it was
like [ __ ] two seconds we walked in
the lady's like hello and we're like
hello she was cool as [ __ ]
gave it to us and i i felt fine
my arm was a little sore but only for
like
you know about 16 hours that was it was
like getting any other [ __ ] shot
it's like getting any other shot and now
i feel great and i i get my next one in
a couple of weeks and uh you know
there's
there's you know there's like no nothing
to worry about
you know i feel i feel the exact
i feel exactly the same way what you
guys do if i slowly lost my mind
i feel exactly the same way i did before
so if you're [ __ ] nervous
um i can tell you
that pharmaceutical companies shot
something into me
about 48 hours ago and i feel i feel
fine
so there you go isn't that all you need
48 hours but you know
us gingers you know they say that you
know
don't they say that we can take more
pain
something like that some that's some of
those internet [ __ ] things
i remember reading that i'm like that
isn't true i get cold before anybody
else
i always need to put a jacket on i mean
it doesn't help that there's no roof
left on the house over here
um so anyway yeah i did it
i feel good about it and uh i everybody
i know is basically
wanting to do it now i don't know what's
going on in [ __ ]
uh flat earth world and i don't care
and uh i don't i don't know why they
have to
it's just why does the news insist
on showing the dumbest versions of
everything
they just they just cannot [ __ ]
they just rubber it's just rubbernecking
okay i am you know it was a group of
people that were all protesting they're
sick of staying inside you know which is
[ __ ] hilarious it's like you know we
don't want to stay inside so we're
basically going to do the behavior
that's making everybody stay inside
right
okay so they're more there's always
morons you know
i'm a [ __ ] but why [ __ ] show that
let's try to spin it
positive man um
i think uh i think we're gonna be we're
all gonna be good enough people are
gonna get it and then it's just gonna
burn itself out
and but then again i was wrong this time
last year so take all this with the
grain of salt and this whole [ __ ]
boogeyman of like it's mutating and blah
blah
i think they'll they'll get that under
wraps pretty quick you know what i mean
it's like we just took out its brother
we we we know what
we know what this [ __ ] thing is now
and uh
having never really done any scientific
background i i feel i'm confident i am
confident
with my lack of scientific i just want
it to be better
that's it all right and things are
coming back motogp is back
that's wrong song um i haven't watched
the race [ __ ] let me see if they posted
it
the [ __ ] race has come on at like you
know
i don't know like three four o'clock in
the morning and i got to get my beauty
sleep there let's see here moto gp
let's see if it's up they were in qatar
qatar qatar you never thought they could
take it that far
uh moto sports that's not what i wanted
i think f1
is coming back to moto
gp.com
all right let's see okay
no no that's not what i want that's not
what i want i'm trying to avoid
i go to calendar it's still view results
[ __ ] oh wait this is the official test
one shakedown first full test official
test
oh the official grant oh okay okay i
guess it doesn't start till next week
march 28th cannot wait
mark marquez is back the king the
reigning king
is back and um
i want to see all last year because last
year he broke his humorous
and um he came back the next race and
then had to shut it down it was [ __ ]
amazing got back that quick but he made
the really smart move
in the long run obviously to take the
[ __ ] year off so then there was all
these other people
maverick vignales and all of that [ __ ]
um
that we're able to uh
i'm seeing remember the name fabio
cuatro all of these people
mark marquez's brother whatever the hell
his name is
alex van halen marquez and uh they all
stepped up and won races and or came
close and all of that type of stuff so
i don't know i think being the leader of
the pack and all of that stuff gives you
a little bit of
uh swagger and it's gonna be interesting
to see when he comes back
if everybody falls back in line like
when when mickey rourke came back to
town in rumblefish
or they all kind of like hey old man
things have changed around here you know
it's gonna be fun to see
i think i like to think um
so anyway um i got
i got two spots tonight i did uh two
shows friday
i'm getting ready because next weekend
i'm out at the rose bowl
the granddaddy of them all harmony i'm
doing some stand up
out there for the comedy store and
they're hoping that this is their last
outdoor show that they're going to be
doing
and um
i'm looking forward to doing that it's
gonna be like 500 cars
um i'm really excited about that and
then the next day
i do my new zealand australia
zoom show hopefully my last one of those
and i'm gonna [ __ ] go off on that one
like i have been lately i just been
saying all this crazy [ __ ]
and been having fun going up in front of
really young crowds i'm telling you i'm
loving this new generation
of kids um the generation
right behind the poor put upon
millennials
who they just made them have to care
about everything
it's going to be funny to watch
millennials in their midlife crisis
you know and rather than getting like a
toupee and if
you you know they'll probably cure
baldness by them but whatever uh and
getting a [ __ ] corvette convertible
i think it's just gonna be them just
like not giving a [ __ ]
and just being like edgy like the new
thing will be like in their 40s like
edgy [ __ ] comics or some [ __ ] i don't
know
it's gonna have to that energy the fun
that they didn't let them have
i feel like at some point you know you
could only keep the lid on that for so
long so
i think the next version of girls gone
wild will be just
cougars in their 40s that are
millennials
that's my prediction um
and a woman will direct it
okay so then it won't feel sexual
assaulty
and then all the women can say that
they're brave and that they're taking
ownership of their own breastuses
i think that that's what's going to
happen okay but like i said a year ago
this time i was really wrong
um so i've been uh
studying my ass off for this uh
instrument rating of my pilot's license
and uh i got the x-plane 11 set up
with the [ __ ] i got the uh i got the
pedals i got everything
and um i've been flying holding patterns
and that type of [ __ ] and i kind of have
that down
i understand you know how to break up
direct parallel
and teardrop um the thing i was working
on today and i was i just
my whole scan just went out the [ __ ]
window was
um ascending and descending in the
pattern while not having my airspeed go
up
just gave me like you know
fits today jesus christ you know you
just want to make little
little corrections little corrections
and i was like i would get so focused on
[ __ ] because you're supposed to just
with your scan right i think i've talked
about this enough just imagine
you got your speedometer imagine you had
six speedometers except they were all
telling you something different
and you got your one main one and you're
always looking at that one and then
occasionally you look you know you
glance the one to the right then go back
to the main one
and then lower right back to the main
one uh directly below back to the main
one lower left back to the main one uh
just to the left back to the main so you
always look at the main one
and that main um attitude indicator
once you kind of lock stuff in with with
the speed and everything
you know how to maintain level flight
that's what the gauge is showing you but
then also when you do standard rate
turns you know where to put that needle
so you don't really have to look at your
turn coordinator and as long as you know
where to keep that ball you really don't
have to look at your altimeter or your
vsi and you can almost start to see it
in your peripheral vision
and then the lonely one the middle child
for me
is the uh airspeed indicator and now
that i'm trying to ascend to descend or
whatever or even just maintain my
[ __ ] altitude
because i still haven't quite figured
out how to trim out this thing um
it's been a uh that's been a bear for me
to figure out but uh i just do it
every single [ __ ] day for like a half
hour
and um i've been having a really good
time
and i recently on a simulator did my
first
ils approach um where it had the thing
where i had to keep the [ __ ] dots
right on this
on on the center of the hsi
i mean sorry the attitude indicator and
all of that [ __ ] and it's just like
i felt like my [ __ ] head was going to
explode but every time you do it
you know it's because you're behind the
aircraft when you're when you're sort of
learning
so then you got to play catch-up and
then you do quick movements which causes
more [ __ ] problems but
i've been watching all of these videos
if you want to just
[ __ ] get this [ __ ] scared out of you
watch these videos and also as just a
passenger it'll get you to stop bitching
about [ __ ]
commercial airline flights you know when
you're landing
you know and they're going through the
clouds when you realize everything that
these guys are [ __ ] men and women are
doing men and ladies gee
the brave women that are up there right
let's not get in trouble here bill
um you cannot [ __ ] believe
like everything that is going on the
fact that they get you on the ground in
in the meantime they have all of your
lives in their hands is [ __ ]
incredible
let me see this thing glider
instrument um
was it new zealand
see if i can find this oh my god i have
one that you have to [ __ ] watch
look up this is this is the [ __ ]
this is the youtube video of the week
that i want you guys to watch i watched
this [ __ ] thing
and had my hand over my mouth like i was
watching
the [ __ ] i don't know the blair witch
whatever movie you found the scariest
um these guys are in a glider
and i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing but there's there's there's a hole
in the clouds where they can punch
through and they decide not to and they
go further into the clouds
and i hear the instructor's voice start
to get panicked
dude my [ __ ] balls were pulling up
into me okay you got to see this called
glider
imc which means instrument
meteorological conditions which means
you're basically flying in the [ __ ]
clouds
uh mana watu new zealand
m-a-n-a-w-a-t-u new zealand
you have to [ __ ] watch this
okay and you know what this actually got
me watching all these glider
videos and those [ __ ] things are
amazing and what i kind of like about
them
is you don't have to worry about engine
failure there is no [ __ ] engine
um and i was reading these posts that
says if before you learn how to fly a
plane if you had
if you learn how to fly a glider like
what that does
for you as far as understanding the
physics and all of that just of
flying it sounds like an incredible uh
education but anyways
check this thing out because um
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
not the video you want to watch that's
just the clip
that's the clip and then if you want to
watch the guy break it down
the name of the video is spin spin spin
exclamation point
um and this guy uh on this thing
what's his name here i don't know how to
read
blan cor carla rio i don't know what
he breaks down first of all he explained
something that i didn't even know that
basically how you
maintain your your your balance and your
sense of where you are
is not only your inner it's your inner
ear with your vision
and when you take your vision away that
thing in your ear no longer works
so if you once you get into a plane or
an aircraft and you go into like a spin
like the way the physics of that works
you still feel stuck to your seat it's
like the carnival ride remember those
little chairs that would spin around
and you totally like you know at a 45
degree angle if you weren't moving you'd
fall out of the chair if you weren't
strapped in
but moving you wouldn't even need to be
strapped in the chair it's like when
they [ __ ] uh that one remember the
carnival ride when you stood against the
wall
and they'd spin you around fast enough
and take the floor out and you're like
what the [ __ ] and then somebody across
from you puked
it was a [ __ ] nightmare it's the same
thing so you're in the clouds and you're
spinning and you feel like you're flying
straight and level
because your vision has been taken away
and now your only
your ears are are listening to your ass
instead of your eyes and
um i i cannot tell you guys if you're
really into if you're just a nerd for
aviation if you just get into like
instrument flying and just sort of
dabble in it just
look at it it is the most fascinating
[ __ ] thing
ever and you can really see how in an
instant
where somebody regardless of how many
hours they have
you know 5 ten fifteen thousand [ __ ]
hours if
they are not current because it's it's a
skill that will you know it's just like
doing cardio you know you're running up
hills
you can walk up a hill no problem you
don't do it for a couple months you go
halfway up the hill you're [ __ ]
winded and need to sit down
the same thing happens with this skill
set where i i kind of felt like once
you're instrument rated
that you okay i know how to do this and
it's just like
i think you know after i get this rating
and i will get it i'm thinking positive
um i am going to uh always
have my simulator hooked up and i will
always be doing
these uh at the very least flying these
patterns in
in approaches so i i keep my my scan
doesn't break down
god forbid but i would never fly and
[ __ ] like that anyways
and then i would just you know do an
instrument approach
a couple of times a month with an
instructor
and then on that same flight all right
let's do auto rotations and i really
think that that's the way
to do it and i feel like guys that i
have met in aviation that have been
flying
you know for 50 years without incident
um
are all people that are you know sort of
by the book
and all it takes is you know a little
lapse in judgment and just being like
hey
i know what the [ __ ] i'm doing you know
that's one of those things
the most trouble i've ever gotten or the
biggest failures i've ever gotten into
in my life is when i re i just i got
this
i i know what i'm doing
that's not necessarily true but i have
gotten in trouble a lot thinking that
way although sometimes when i just go
i'm going to [ __ ] kill i do
well why do you guys listen to me don't
you love how i make points and then just
take them away immediately
um anyway
uh all right so old sober
[ __ ] straight edge march um
continues and i got to tell you it's
it's been it's getting hard
21 [ __ ] days in i'm almost there 10
more [ __ ] days
jesus christ [ __ ] [ __ ] um
well it's the 21st today it's 22nd when
you're listening to this
this was my big my big thing for this
month
i mentioned a few weeks ago that i
ordered chocolate malt
because i i really was just craving some
sort of excitement
because i'm not eating any sugar
there's nothing really salty in my diet
it's sort of this bland
stuff which i've you know i'm going to
continue with the veggie [ __ ] but i just
don't think
i get really bored roy i get bored with
it
which means i think it means i don't
have enough recipes so i need some more
recipes that i can kind of
add to my thing but i'm really getting
tired some of my go-to ones but then
again when i was a kid
i really got sick of chicken out the
king chipped beef on toast
cube steaks um
tuna casserole oh my god that was the
worst
um what do they call those noodles that
she put in
my mother used to put these were they
chinese noodles
asian noodles what do you call them
chinese i'm not afraid to do this now
noodles is that what they are
yeah those little [ __ ] no the little
hard things that's what she said
um i don't know what they were there was
they looked like they were toasted and
she would put those in there
and my older brother told me that they
were worms
and it was like heated up tuna which i
already [ __ ] can't stand and then he
told me there was worms in them and oh
my god i can't remember how long i sat
there did you guys have a mom like mine
or whatever she made you had to you're
going to sit there until you
finish that she had a
a sandwich spread which were really big
back in the day
sandwich spreads and when i tell you
this
this sandwich spread looked like
vomit i mean
it was just like uh let me see
sandwich spread that's [ __ ] showing
me mayonnaise here let me see if i can
find this thing
vintage sandwich spread
recipe see oh my god part of the
internet am i on now oh there it is
yeah oh god i almost [ __ ] gag looking
at it
oh my god oh
it didn't taste bad it just looked it
was like
i guess this has ground up bologna in
mayonnaise and then you could just you
know
just it up however you wanted to so my
mother would make this [ __ ]
and we it was funny she knew we didn't
like it
but we had so many kids that it was just
like i don't have [ __ ] time
the menu is what it what it is when you
get when you move out someday you can
eat whatever you want to eat i was like
you're in this house
that's [ __ ] right so she would be making
it
she had like a meat grinder and she'd be
[ __ ] grinding up the [ __ ]
hand [ __ ] thing just grinding this
[ __ ] up and we would just see it like um
wow are you making sandwich
you making that sandwich mom it looks
like throw up it does not
[Music]
she just would make it and then she put
it on white bread and we would just sit
there
and then she'd be eating oh there's
nothing wrong with it there's nothing
wrong with it and we would just be
sitting there
mom i don't want to eat it yo you
straighten up
sit up straighten your seat you're going
to eat that and we would just sit there
and sit there and sit there and in a way
i think she did it on purpose because
then she had all of her kids just
she knew where we were and we were just
sitting there and then she could go off
clean the house or pay some bills
whatever the [ __ ] she had to do
and we would just be sitting there in
lockdown staring at these [ __ ]
sandwiches that looked like somebody
took some cold puke and put it between
two slices of wonder bread just [ __ ]
sitting there so i remember
uh i remember sitting there so long at
one point the bread was starting to get
stale and i'm not exaggerating that
like a couple of hours my ass was
falling asleep on the [ __ ] wooden
chair
and then one of my younger brothers got
up
and he had half a [ __ ] sandwich left
and i just finished mine and then he
took his
and he dropped it behind the stereo my
dad had this big like back you know
hi-fi system so there was like you know
all the records were on the bottom and
then the stereo was on top and then
there was a thing that came up
behind it had a back on it up there was
the speakers he dropped it behind there
and oh my god i it was one of the best
laughs of of that year of my childhood
i don't know what about it struck me is
so funny there was something about the
fact that i ate mine and he didn't
and that he had the balls to do it but
was also
like young and dumb enough to not
realize that he was gonna get caught
the whole [ __ ] thing was just so
goddamn funny
that we were all just sitting there
crying laughing and then my
mother comes in and all the sandwiches
were gone and we
had these shitty grins in our faces
we were all laughing she's like you ate
them all up
like yeah yeah we ate him and she knew
we were full of [ __ ] but she was [ __ ]
busy
[Music]
so i don't know how long it took for
that [ __ ] thing to start smelling or
what or what the [ __ ] happened
the funny thing is is we all forgot
about it
so when she was saying what is that
smell do you guys smell that there's a
smell in here
we were just like yeah i don't know what
that is you know i
did you know was there an easter egg
somebody didn't find we had no [ __ ]
idea what it was and then
she finally [ __ ] found the thing
oh my god it was so funny it was [ __ ]
hilarious and then he got busted
and got paddled you know my dad was in a
fraternity and he kept the paddle so my
mother used to [ __ ] hit us with that
back when you could do [ __ ] like that
um back when you could do [ __ ] like that
i mean one time she was driving home she
said
two of my younger brothers she said if
you two don't knock it off i'm pulling
over the side of
they're going to spank your bare asses
right on the side of the street
and she was so mellow you know she
wasn't the vaulter one she was mellow so
that we just kept testing her and my
younger brothers did and she [ __ ]
pulled over and she did it and the funny
thing is she did it on the driver's side
too it was uh
what the [ __ ] was it i forget what that
thing was
i remember it was she was doing it and i
was like oh my god and i was laughing my
ass off
my brothers were crying and people were
driving by laughing
baby like beeping horns they thought it
was the funniest [ __ ] thing ever
now somebody would videotape that and
they would have taken
her kids away you know and my mother was
a [ __ ] great mother and we
deserve you know when i look back i
[ __ ] deserved every goddamn time
every [ __ ] time
she was right and it's funny i have
absolutely no anger
or issues about getting
getting [ __ ] hit with that [ __ ]
paddle zero
and what all i do is just laugh about
the [ __ ] that i did
sprayed a garden hose through the
[ __ ] screen window my brother one
time that [ __ ] soaked the kitchen he
pissed me off
i remember he threw dishwater at me
because we had to do the dishes every
other night
we had a night right um
that was our chore or whatever and i was
giving him [ __ ]
because it was his night to do dishes
right so i was running my yap
so he took a handful of hot soapy water
and just slapped me
off the back of my head and neck as hard
as he [ __ ] could
to the point you know i saw like stars
and then i turn around so mad and he's
looking at me like what i'm your older
brother what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
oh i showed him i went outside right out
the side door
and what was hilarious is right as
he figured out what i was gonna do i had
turned the water on
and i just missed him i just missed him
and then i was so mad i wasn't thinking
about
the ramifications of my act
and it all went through the [ __ ]
window and i immediately brought it down
and i shut off the water and ran around
to the other side of the house
and all i was thinking was like wow that
was a lot of water
my mother's probably going in there
right now trying to figure out what's
going to happen and then you know
they never will happen never will happen
get in here
the best thing was was you got the
beating first and then you had to clean
up
so then you were doing that that that
[ __ ] cry
is just sitting there with the paper
towels as they giving you [ __ ] for using
too many paper towels
and clean all of that up look at that
wall
um yeah it was a [ __ ] hilarious time
a [ __ ] hilarious time so anyway
getting back to this
so i don't i've just been like sober the
whole [ __ ] month i've been sleeping
like a goddamn
baby just been sleeping great and um
which is really you know the secret to a
long life eating well and so
oh you know you know what the secret to
a long life is having no
fun whatsoever so i'm looking forward to
this chocolate malt last night so i
bought this
malt so there's a difference between a
frap or a shake
and a malt and all it is is that you put
you season it with the chocolate malt
and the malt i can't
it gives this taste this flavor this
aftertaste it's
[ __ ] incredible so last night
i took out the blender you know
i had a pint of [ __ ] vanilla ice
cream haagen-dazs i believe
right i found this great youtube video
this guy
going you run some hot water on the
outside for a minute of the pine ice
cream that'll melt the
the edges so then you can just squeeze
it right out work like a charm
poured some milk in i'm not gonna i over
blend it i pulverized it i i
over mixed it but it's my first one so i
can forgive myself
so i mix that and then i put in
some chocolate quick
mix that because at that point you had
the vanilla shake at that point then the
chocolate quick
quick i went back to the 70s remember
that rich and thick and chocolate but
you can't
drink it slow if it's quick i forget how
it went had that rabbit right
they had strawberry and chocolate right
so
um i [ __ ] made that right
everything was good and then you put in
the malt in the end heaping tablespoon
and then a heaping half tablespoon
you mix that [ __ ] up you put [ __ ]
whipped cream on top and a little
[ __ ] cherry
you bring it out to your wife and your
daughter
and one for you and i'm gonna tell you
something everybody's happy
everybody's [ __ ] happy oh it was
delicious
it was [ __ ] delicious so now
you know how i'm wired is it's like well
i'm gonna learn
how to make the strawberry one and the
vanilla one and all of this [ __ ] and
it's like what am i gonna do go buy
have a pint of ice cream every [ __ ]
night you become a tub of [ __ ]
so i had to be like look you get one of
those a month
maybe two a month maybe i'll do that two
a month
um but if you know
i learned about chocolate malts from
bob's big boy
out in ohio and the great state of
michigan not saying ohio is not great
either but
great ohio and michigan two of my
favorite states right
and you know i had relatives family out
there back when i was young
and back on the east coast they had
fraps
they didn't have malted milk at least
around the where i was
so we would go out there and we couldn't
figure out why they tasted so much
better
because they just taste [ __ ] better
and i remember my brother coming back
and going to friendlies and brighams
all those ice cream places back on the
east coast
and ordering a frap and he goes is there
malt in it and they were like what is he
cause is it like a malted
milkshake and hey it's a you know
dude it's a [ __ ] frap
we don't take special orders here and
seeing my brother be so disappointed and
we love those things so much do you know
my entire time
when i was on the road i had an
unwritten rule that if i went by a bob's
big boy
back when they had those things i would
go in there and i would get a burger and
fries
and i would get a chocolate malt and it
took me back to when i was a kid and i
used to visit my grandparents out in the
midwest
and we would drive out there in a
caprice classic
station wagon the fake wooden sides and
we would drive all the way out there
and just what was amazing back then this
is like the 70s and 80s
is when you traveled that far back then
[ __ ] looked
way different even the corporation
stores were different they just had
different chains before like the
walmarts just kind of bought everything
up
and the starbucks and all of that [ __ ]
and you could go to some really unique
places and just see stuff and like we
had never heard of bob's big boy or
you know chocolate malts and all that
type of [ __ ] um
man that was so much [ __ ] fun
goddammit that was fun i gotta make sure
i do road trips
with my kids because i hated the [ __ ]
drive
it was exciting in the beginning but
then the air conditioning could never
get past the front seat
you know and you'd be in the back seat
just dying wanting to put the window
down
they'd be like don't put the window down
and then my dad had a theory that if you
kept the back window of the station
wagon down it sucked the ac
all the way through the back which i
don't think is true um so
anyway it's just we were all impatient i
think that's what it was
and we used to drive out there and we
would listen to the mills brothers
on uh on
[ __ ] eight-track or because it was
cassette if it was the early 80s
you know what the [ __ ] was some of those
goddamn songs jesus christ i'm going way
back into the vault on this one
up a lazy river by
driving in a [ __ ] station wagon
oh [ __ ] um anyway
it was funny that was the world i was
living in while movies like over the
edge
ate it you stinkin pig those things were
being made and there was kids like that
and i was sort of an amalgam of both i
was like this [ __ ]
norman rockwell painting looking [ __ ]
howdy doody looking kid
who'd get excited about a cheeseburger
and a [ __ ] malt
and then also i was vandalizing [ __ ]
houses that were
stealing from them like uh when they
were first being built we used to go
down and steal lumber
so we could build our own tree fort um
you know [ __ ] like that dumbass stuff
all right let me let's do the
advertising here for the week
um oh this is the perfect advertiser for
this week
during march madness and i am rooting
for the university of michigan that's
what i'm going for
but it's weird this uh tonight they're
playing or this afternoon i'm not sure
of the schedule they're playing the lsu
tigers
hail to the victors two great school
songs
and uh i think i got a route for
michigan
i gotta root for michigan because ohio
state's been talking so much [ __ ] with
like the football and ohio state got
bounced out
a first or second round i don't know
they were 15 lost to a second seat so i
believe that's the first round but
anyways if you want to gamble on this
stuff and have a great
[ __ ] time with one of the great
sporting events
out of the year march madness march is
here and the madness has
officially begun here at my bookie how
the [ __ ] you doing
uh shoot your shot to score big on the
non-stop
action with my bookie
i hope you're all enjoying the
tournament in the my bookie bracket
contest
where you could win up to 25 grand my
bookie takes the action to the next
level with in-game
live betting for all your favorite games
who do you think will win march
madness uh talk about who you'd bet on i
bet on the uh
i've been on [ __ ] uh university of
michigan i i
watched a criminally low amount
of college basketball this year my
college hoop teams are
university of michigan uh the kansas
jayhawks
and ucla those are the three so i got an
east coast the midwest even though
michigan's considered midwest
the detroit wedwings to me i don't know
they're still on east coast time they're
all [ __ ] east coast
east eastern time zone so i got one in
east
each time zone and i don't i don't i
don't [ __ ] with the mountain
[ __ ] uh so i i put my money on
uh michigan we shall see we shall see
uh anyway it doesn't matter whether
you're filling out multiple brackets
betting the national championship winner
that's what i did or simply looking for
player and game props my bookie has you
covered
sign up today at mybookie.com dot a
g and use the promo code bird b-u-r-r to
secure a deposit bonus
up to one thousand dollars and make sure
you use my promo code so they know that
i hooked you up
uh mybookie.ag promo code bur burr to
claim your first deposit bonus
college ball nba and nhl no matter the
sport no matter the minute
my bookie puts the action in your hand
with in-game
live betting and with choice and with
choice from thousands of lines and odds
you can turn any game day into payday
bet anything
anytime anywhere with my bookie
so i gotta take a drink here because i
have to keep clearing my throat my
apologies
um all right let's look here what do we
got
let's look uh we got some reeds here we
got some people writing in
hoas home owner associations i learned
what that is our absolute
horseshit hey there billy bag of
vegetables
my wife and i have lived in an hoa
subdivision for nearly 12 years
and will avoid buying into another one
at all costs
once we move out of here yes they
prevent someone from parking a clapped
out el camino next to their house for a
decade
however other other than that it's a
joke
it gives people who can't am i the only
person who gets annoyed when somebody
parks in front of the house
like you feel like those are your spots
when they're not
you know it doesn't really bug me it's
just when there's a car there for a
while
and it's just like do you think i'm
gonna come out here and look at the same
car
every [ __ ] day i want variety buddy
get this thing the [ __ ] out of here
right um
anyway however other than other than the
el camino thing other than that it's a
joke
it gives people who can't afford real
exclusivity the notion
uh that that is what they are buying
into we live in a subdivision with
cookie-cutter houses that all have vinyl
siding
that's hilarious and there's an hoa the
hoa fees pay for the pool
that's cool that we have in the
subdivision but we live in chicago so
that gets used maybe four months out of
the year
um there are numerous homes in the
subdivision that are rentals and the
owners
live the owner lives out of state those
properties look like [ __ ]
my wife and i had the pleasure of living
across the street from a known
child molester for five years he's now
in jail awaiting trial on numerous
charges
there is a strict set of guidelines
regarding what you can and can't do
to your house all right here's some of
the can't do's uh no above ground pools
no sheds no chain link fences etc
uh i agree with most of them
but you have knuckleheads who bought
homes here
knew what the restrictions were and
still want to constantly [ __ ]
that they can't have a shed in their
backyard see this is that's the line i
don't get
so are you bitching about them or not um
you say that they suck but
i guess you're saying it definitely
sucks so i'm not gonna do it again but
don't buy in because they tell you what
the rules are
anyway you need to get the hoa to
approve any trees or
bushes that you want to plant they would
have to approve
any significant changes to your home or
property and the good news
is the contacts at the hoa never return
anyone's calls
it's yet another way for someone to make
money off of your property
yeah and be in charge i mean the upside
of an hoa
is i have a buddy of mine that lives out
here
uh in this neighborhood and you know
that whole
adage is that it saying where a man's
home is his castle
this guy literally built a castle
and it looks like a two-story white
castle restaurant
and it's next to all of these beautiful
beautiful homes it is
a [ __ ] eyesore and there was no hoa
until this [ __ ] [ __ ] did that and
then they were just like jesus christ we
need to do something to prevent this
from happening again which i understand
um i understand it for that
reason now i don't understand no
chain-link fence
not even around your backyard what if
you have a dog
um the shrubs and all of that are kind
of weird
it's chicago what are you gonna plant a
cactus
yeah it just seems like you know you're
paying somebody to just [ __ ]
be control freaks and then is there
every year can you
vote for new leaders of the hoa can you
run for that or is it sort of
locked in when you get in there if
anybody can
let me know what that deal is um
because there's a way to do that then
you just run for
office then it's funny then it's this
little mini election and then the people
that are in power
they'd start branded you a communist
or a libtard or whatever the [ __ ] these
political idiots say all right
royal london
dear billy wanker tits cheers from just
outside of london
uh he says i love your take on the
royals i once spoke
up in school and said that i thought we
should just sell off the royal palace
and give back all the riches that were
stolen
uh i'm not a dumb [ __ ] so i suggest that
we keep some money for the poor plebs
here
and get most of it what's a pleb oh god
did i just say something that's
offensive over there
okay british slang pleb oh god look at
that sandwich spread
so disgusting british slang plebs
uh if someone refers to people's pledges
they mean they are of low
social class or do not appreciate
culture i knew it
it just didn't sound complimentary
um i'm not as dumb as i look so i
suggest okay blah blah blah
uh i'll never forget what the teacher
told me he said stop being a wanker
and get back to reality we're stuck
and doomed um
yeah you know some when you get old
that's kind of where you end up
you're kind of like yeah there's no way
that's the [ __ ] is is what it is and
there's no way to stop it
now that doesn't mean you can't stop it
it just means you don't have
you know you don't have the gandhi gene
and you're not going to turn it around
meaning me and and your teacher so
um yeah that is [ __ ] that whole thing
is why i like how the
the the royals came back it was like
right she totally misrepresented us
[Laughter]
oh god wouldn't it be hilarious if she
was if she just totally lied that would
be [ __ ]
hilarious um
then you just you wouldn't know what to
think you wouldn't know what to think
um who knows i have no idea but i'm
[ __ ] tired of that story
all right booty's genocide
good day bill oh look at this
everybody's writing it
look at that knife um so it appears
buddhists are no better than any other
religion
and oh because i asked you know when i
was talking about buddha bowls i was
like how soon before that becomes
offensive to somebody
um and i was but wait did the buddhists
ever
you know do psycho [ __ ] like every
religion seems to have done
killed a bunch of innocent people so
this person's writing in geday bill
uh so it appears buddhists are no better
than
the other religions in the myanmar
burma there is currently a genocide oh
[ __ ] still going on against the minority
wrong young rohingya
muslims
all right wait a second in australia
wait i'm confused here i didn't know
oh so are the buddhists killing the
muslims
well they're the minority so i imagine
they're the one getting the the bad end
of the stick wait i got to look this up
oh he gave me a link open the link
oh jesus here comes some depressing [ __ ]
the rohingya genocide this is a series
of ongoing persecutions
by the myanmar formerly burmese
government
of the muslim rohingya people the
genocide has consisted of two
phases well this is government this
isn't religion
right i'm not saying what they're doing
is right here the
genocide is consisted of two phases to
date the first was a military crackdown
that occurred
from october 2016 to january 2017
and the second has been occurring since
august 2017.
the crisis forced over a million i'm
saying this right rohingya
to flee to other countries most led to
bangladesh
resulting in the creation of the world's
largest refugee camp
while others escaped to india thailand
malaysia and other parts of south and
southeast asia
the persecution of the roy hinga muslims
in
myanmar dates back to the 1970s
since then the rohingya people have been
persecuted on a regular basis
by government oh and nationalist
buddhists there it is
wow yeah well there's just something
about religion
something about it um
in australia a lot of the very few
refugees we actually
let in are roynia's fleeing the violence
i've never understood how people can be
so dedicated to religion
once they discovered dinosaurs but i
suppose to each their own cheers and go
[ __ ] yourself
i thought you would say how you can be
so dedicated to your religion when you
find out what your religion has done to
other people
not practicing what they preach and that
there's a heaven in hell yet they're
behaving like this
and you're kind of like well then that
really makes me feel like you're you're
making all of this up if you're not
afraid of going to hell
because you clearly aren't if you're
behaving this way right
all right world gone mad hey billy rusty
bollocks
bullocks i'm matt from the uk
all right hi well hello matt from the uk
been a massive
fan of your comedy for years love the
podcast and your thoughts on woke
culture across the pond
no matter how crazy it's got in the
states the lunatics have taken over the
asylum
in blighty oh god here we go more
english slang english slang
blighty is that mean in spades english
slang
blighty is a bridge of slang
it often or often specifically england
oh it says oh for great britain
okay taking over the asylum in blighty
which is england who knew i didn't know
i don't know if you've heard
but there is i love that you guys write
in your slang
i i find that very uh it's you know you
learn something and then it's also like
it's very
you're talking to me like you talk to
somebody where you're from which
i think is really cool so thank you i
don't know if you've heard but there has
been an a
a a horrific murder carried out in our
country
allegedly by a serving police officer
oh god do i want to know about this the
response from some of our politicians
most notably
baroness jones a baroness
um it's got to be a fun life to be a
baroness
just picture a driving like cruella de
vil all [ __ ] face trying to steal
puppies
um has been to to propose a 6 p.m curfew
for men in order to make women
safe
what in the [ __ ] i'm all for keeping
women safe but this is completely
ridiculous as far as i'm concerned
i'm wondering how you and your ginger
wisdom would react
to this rampant [ __ ] wittery
uh keep up the good work much love to
nia and the kids and without further ado
go [ __ ] yourself
um i just think that uh women are just
sort of women like that which are the
ones that would be in power if women ran
the world
are just sort of showing that um how
that the flaw of humanity does not stop
with males women are just as [ __ ]
flawed and
is just as cruel and crazy and
willing to take away freedoms and just
look out their own head and don't have
empathy yeah that's [ __ ]
that's crazy um
maybe hilarious though if they enforced
it and then guys actually just complied
with it
and then we would create this whole new
thing which would be great the women
would be leaving
and we just have our guy friends come
over
before the curfew and then they just
have to stay there and spend the night
and we would still end up having a
better time than they did
you know i'm telling you i'm
[ __ ] telling you we would still have
a good time
um we're just smart enough and we're
just dumb enough i really think the male
brain
when it comes to fun i just think women
are just too goddamn smart
to have a good time a lot of the times
um or maybe
they can't let their hair down because
there's a bunch of guys out there i
don't think i'm coming around to this
if there's like a curfew at 6 00 p.m
oh my god oh honey i'd love to take you
out but i mean i i can't go out so i
you should go out with your friends then
you can hang in you can watch sports
do a zoom hang have your buddies come
over
oh my god that'd be great
then you'd you could have a you could
have like a [ __ ] guy
speak easy on every block some guy's
[ __ ] basement
and everybody every [ __ ] kent right
just
hops the fence and goes in there
and hangs out and then what are the cops
going to enforce it you bring them in
you hook them up a little pappy van
winkle
you know that's it it's going to take
some male feminist elliott ness to shut
that [ __ ] down
all right reform liberal douche and kids
in cages
um all right dear wilford
f uh burr i'll cut right to it i spent
years defending the democratic party and
the american left for a while now
i had a problem with some of the things
obama did but i always made excuses for
the bank
bailout uh yeah a lot of people did in
which he instructed
his attorney general that they would not
be holding the financial
megaliths accountable for what they did
to the country
i know it's unbelievable they got away
with it i thought well
maybe he had a bigger plan during trump
i would always cringe when someone said
they hated trump but they liked him
better than hillary
especially when they said they could
overlook something
horrendous all right
after all that and that was first months
of this biden presidency
i'm beginning to release realize i think
you were trying to say that i've been
a cheerleading douchebag i actually
thought
biden would be a good president i
finally caved when i read about the
expansion of cheap housing slash
cages for migrant children separated
from their children
and for actually banning reporters
indefinitely from all border facilities
wow i posted something on my instagram
and someone replied trump made it
impossible for him to do otherwise yeah
that's that [ __ ]
that's that sports fan way of looking at
politics we
never do anything wrong they do anything
everything wrong if we do something
wrong it's because of something that
they did and the people on the right do
it too
uh this is very not true but it's an
argument i made during obama's
presidency when he continued
bush-era crimes i know i know he gave
yeah he
drone-bombed the [ __ ] drone bomb
weddings and all of this [ __ ] and
everybody out here in hollywood just
can't get enough of this guy
i spent for or bill clinton who [ __ ]
bombed the city because he [ __ ] got a
[ __ ] blow job from a pa um i spent
four act
i spent four something acting as if
about four years
i don't there's a number four then it
says acting as if
there was any difference between parties
i've heard you say this for a year but
it never sank in i feel like a phone
don't feel like a phony you're just
realizing something that's really
important and as far as trump and op
and obama there was certain things that
trump would will be better at and biden
will be better at but in general
they're going to steer the ship in the
same direction all right like i think
biden's going to be a little bit better
with the pandemic thing
um i don't think he's a contrarian and
won't listen to doctors and metal
medical people and he's enforcing mass i
think that that is smart but he is
without a [ __ ] doubt
and you knew it going in a [ __ ] war
monger and he's already pulling that
same [ __ ] rhetoric rhetoric
about iran having weapons of mass
destruction
and you know all of that rhetoric is
just serving the oil companies
because if anyone's driven a tesla or
been blown off the line by one
with two kids in the back in a [ __ ]
you know picnic basket and
blowing these porsches and [ __ ] like off
the line like
we don't need as much of that oil as
we're consuming we just don't
and we could put those [ __ ] out of
business and they wouldn't have money
for plutonium or whatever the [ __ ] it is
you buy for all that you could just shut
it all down but
where is the money in that so i think
it's just up
to regular people you have to be we got
to be nice to one another and you have
to respect people with different
political points of views
than yours and i think it is healthy
to ha to hang out with people on both
sides of the aisle
and i don't think it's a healthy thing
to just surround yourself with people
who only think the way you do you're
essentially living
in the entourage bubble and if you see
these celebrities that have entourages
and everybody's just like oh yes yes oh
my god brilliant
you watch them they're not tethered to
anything anymore
and they just they just float off into
[ __ ] space
so um
yeah he's definitely you know and by now
so was saying that you know
that the taliban's getting going again
in afghanistan
and it's just like you know he's just he
just keeps beating the drums of that
[ __ ]
and it's like okay well what about
what's
what we were just reading about
where earlier [ __ ] was that going on
that genocide we were just reading about
what you hear
nothing about over here um
in burma you hear nothing about it i bet
if they were sitting on [ __ ] oil
we would just we have to go over there
and save
then we would be saving muslims
you know it's just it is what it is
um all right friend is dating a homeless
guy
all right this is interesting you know
dating a homeless guy now isn't that bad
i don't think
you know it's before they were a little
on the crazier side but now so many
people have lost so much in a year that
somebody could be
you know you gotta how long have they
been homeless freshly homeless
um hey bill i know you love it when the
ladies write in
here's i love to hear from the ladies
are you doing this sweetheart uh here's
a doozy for you
a friend of mine went through a pretty
rough breakup last year with her husband
oh before i forget i heard a [ __ ]
great song on this playlist
uh oh by the way that chilled cow
whoever told me to listen to that
lo-fi chill cow i [ __ ] love it
and it led me to some like uh
what the [ __ ] neo soul [ __ ] lo-fi
[ __ ] i just drive around trying not to
get mad in traffic
listening to that [ __ ] uh
oh my god peggy lee is that all there is
have a listen to that [ __ ] song
one of my great lines ever in a movie
and i'm sorry in the songs
let's break out the booze
i mean it's just it's an amazing song
about i think being chemically uh
literally like chemically depressed for
your entire life
um amazing song
all right a friend is dating a homeless
guy all right uh all right a friend of
mine went through a pretty real rough
breakup oh she had a rough one okay
last year when her husband a 10 with her
husband of 10 years yeah that would be
brutal
she's been coping pretty well with the
shock and trauma of the breakup so it
must have come out of nowhere
poor thing so i was thrilled when she
told me she was going on a date one
night
oh god when i asked her with who
i was less than thrilled when she
answered the good-looking homeless guy
from the tunnel
well you know with sort of uh you know
he's the uh what do they call the
rebound guy
i tried to voice my concern while trying
not to sound too mean
anyway i was pretty sure one date with
this guy would set her straight
oh my god but no
she continues to post photos online of
their little rendezvous
maybe she went camping a lot and she
missed getting banged in a tent i don't
know
she says i don't know whether she's
banging him and i don't want to know
i've only seen photos of the guy and i
can honestly say
he just looks like a hobo
he's got that boxcar willy look jimmy
crack corn and i don't care
jimmy crack ah look at that pee wee
herman um
am i being overly judgmental in seeing
this situation is only ending with being
chopped up into little pieces
listen there's being liberal and then
there's being stupid
all right if you if she wants to help
this guy
how about a background you are not you
know just meet some guy who lives under
a [ __ ] bridge
and start hanging out with them does she
have kids i don't hear any kids here
anyway i know but by the way whoever
that homeless guy
is he needs to write a book on how to
pick up women
i can tell you that right now all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] driving around their
loud exhaust
cars and ferraris trying to make all
this noise to try and get some [ __ ] and
this guy's [ __ ] living in a goddamn
tent in a [ __ ] empty box
getting some action um
anyway am i being okay uh i know after
the first date he was already
professing his love for her in quite an
embarrassing public manner oh
jesus i take all the book [ __ ] back and
i have suspected from the start he's not
all there
he spotted some [ __ ] story about his
family being wealthy and how he doesn't
want anything from them
and apparently oh my god that's like the
stripper telling you she's going to
college
that's the homeless version of that and
apparently she's taking his stories as
gospel
um ma'am i don't know what's going on
with your friend
either she is the most gullible person
she's been married for
10 years and she's fallen for this
[ __ ]
or she had some sort of psychotic break
during that 10-year
you know after 10 years of marriage and
a breakup wow anyways i guess this is a
perfect example of how some women will
[ __ ] anyone remotely good-looking
regardless of their circumstances we'd
love to hear your opinion opinion
on this [ __ ] up scenario thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself i i am
in an agreement with you i would be
worried that she's gonna end up in
pieces
um yeah and that story i don't buy it
for a [ __ ]
second um
oh god so what do you do you got to be
like the parent here if you tell her to
stay away from the guy she's just going
to run to him
right nobody understands us but
us you know she's hugging him
sound of flies oh god
when they bang do they listen to alice
and change jara flies
album sorry um all right i'm not making
fun of homeless people but i am
concerned with the fact
that i'm concerned for her yeah i i
share your concerns and
uh i would talk to a professional that
can
i don't know what sort of intervention
you have
do you put up a tent next to their tent
and just unzip it when they show up
just margaret you probably wonder why
i'm in this tent
no it's not because my parents are
actually wealthy and i don't want
anything from them no that's not the
reason
why uh i'm concerned for your safety
safety safety that's your voice echoing
underneath the [ __ ] overpass
all right vibe music suggestions
uh bonobo bonobo b-o-n-o-b-o
b-o-b-o with an n-o in the middle bonobo
all right let's see what we got here
let's see what we got
here um
[Music]
oh i love it hey man i'm just hanging
out today man
you know listening to this music man
like really makes me think like
like why can't you just date a homeless
person man
he's rejecting his parents wealth
he doesn't need the money
no no he just
needs a honey here we go sorry
sorry i got lost in it i apologize um
okay i like that b-o-n-o-b-o check that
out and
chilled cow or whatever the [ __ ] it was
called i like that one too
uh hey billy big mouth i was listening
to the podcast and i heard you mentioned
you want
a list you want to listen to the lo-fi
chill beats
check out this mandalorian theme tune
remix
uh it's called closes on sunday
mandalorian oh mandalorian okay let's
check this one out
here we go before it's the exact same
song
[Music]
am i out of my mind it's the exact same
song and i'm not joking
oh wait oh no no no i got to both
playing at the same time hate them both
playing at the same time sorry
oh hang on a second
that sounds like somebody practicing a
saxophone
[Music]
oh boy yeah i'll pass on that one uh you
know let me give it a chance i'll fast
forward here
[Music]
all right um
i don't know why that that that part of
the song made me feel like i was in
tokyo and i
had one of those [ __ ] tricked out
cars
and i was gonna i was gonna start
drifting even though i didn't know how
to do it
um all right everybody that is the
podcast
that is the podcast um for this monday
i'm limping along in this straight edge
month
you know i would be a better dad if i
just had one chocolate malt
a month right twice a month
i have to do that ugh oh billy has to
grow up at 52
poor [ __ ] baby all right that's it
you guys go [ __ ] yourselves
all right uh while being nice to one
another how about that something
positive all right and i'll check in on
you
on uh thursday all right i'll see you